[Music]
so
focus kai
try adding another zero to that number
he doesn't renegotiate love now unload
and get lost
can i speak to your manager something
the meta
the legendary cuban bliss
we met girl oh i think i'd remember
meeting you sir
[Music]
that's not yours do you know what it
took your daddy to in this hey it's not
mine yet
you'll see
you're never flying one of these death
traps
[Music]
so you're that ace my bloke's hard eh
best pilot money can buy violet
that word used to mean something
yeah i've heard the stories
your stock system
[Music]
kyrie what are you doing what dad
something scamming the [ __ ]
oh yes
get out of there now
i've lived them and i'll tell you this
girl
flying doesn't make you a violent
what matters is what you can do when
your life is on the line
transferred
eliminated
that's the problem with most pilots i
makes you blind and gets the ones
closest to you
hello little viper
viper on stations
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i know i failed him
[Music]
and they left
worst part was not knowing why
maybe he left because of me
but he died because of you he knew what
he was fighting for
do you
all this time you've done nothing but
tried to get to me
wondering if daddy loved you wasting
your life so you can avenge his
the vengeance is all you get for girl
go ahead and take it but you pull that
trigger
your story ends
[Music]
your father never wanted you to live for
him
he wanted your legacy
to be better
so little viper are you a pilot
or just the sobbing daughter of one
my call sign is valkyrie
and you'll live to remember it
felgety
[Music]
so
goodbye
you